hey guys I'm Ryan right hello there I'm
Veronica and I'm Brandi price Veronica
and I are not seeing next to each other
today because of serious relationship
problems that's our baby outside we have
to put the baby outside because the baby
couldn't be around us while we were
fighting bad diagonal yeah so it's just
outside the front door but we live in a
safe neighborhood brandi is uh you know
I'm a mediator
she's the mediator that's also her dog
actually it's that I thought this was a
neighbor's dog because the neighbor is
pretty vicious
he likes small children I get what you
did with the improv there you denied my
thing totally just change the whole
scene and made it about oh here's my
joke that I want to make it about that
so you did Brandon if you no longer yes
and no but brands always trying to
regulate everybody's humor that is the
section that's the best way to do it
what an ass I would go on jackass what a
jacket there you go yeah sorry for
wasting a minute of your time you know
what I don't hug me I'm scared
Park four let's do this by the way the
creators themselves have said that the
video is open to interpretation if I you
have my own opinion about it
I'm not wrong everyone was like bread is
actually right I just made Veronica
watch the first three very freaky yeah
she's into that kind of stuff that's how
we're gonna repair a relationship
problem oh I guess it's my turn to
choose a card let's see hmm
what is the biggest thing in the world
rides dick that's a tricky one among
can't ask I win with if only there was a
way to learn more about the world here
we go
yes if only there was some way to learn
more information about this future
I'm a victory guy everything made of the
buttons and wires I'd like to show you
inside my fix it to life music justify
how oh maybe you can help us on to this
question what is the big marry every
night baby
my big
- no it's like there is not boy like me
I'm not Felix - a computer actually we
already do you so do you
my name is great news you awaken within
our way way to support your favorite
color
Oh God
Wow amazing
an interesting world
I've never appreciated until now how
much work actually goes into these
videos always thought it was cool and I
always thought it was good but watching
this I was like wow these guys are real
animators and like they know how to play
with the the puppets really well like
the parody on Sesame Street is great I
like how they're not just going through
crazy violence you know like I love how
they went crazy with the digital world
that made it kind of haunting and scary
at the end I like the dark turn that
always happens this dark is the other
ones however it's just I felt like it
was a political commentary about how
social media affects you and yeah how
like their other like there's a bar
graph there's this and it's like the
stuff that you're learning all that
knowledge is there and so you're opening
door number one but you're never really
looking at it you're looking at the fun
you're looking at the fashion you're
looking at the stuff and then finally it
just goes away
yeah I think yeah I saw it as like a
computer is a great team that's deep
yeah deep sorry were you gonna go I
thought you were just saying that's deep
what's happening right now yeah we're
gonna have a fight speak but okay thanks
by the way I love the computer character
and the main computer character was
great you see a computer and you're like
hey you get all this knowledge that you
could use it for and it could be a very
wonderful thing that you have but then
you get addicted to it and then before
you know it you're just doing everything
on your computer all day and then your
brain just gets over flooded with just
digital digital digital that you live in
your computer now you don't live in the
real world do you kind of see a
similarity
matrix they were like in the matrix like
packed into a computer yeah yeah and
also how your social media sites like
the things that you're projecting on the
computer your digital you it's different
than your real you all right it's an
image such an image that your yourself
totally and so you can kind of lose
yourself in that
yeah so that's why they're like oh
you're nothing anymore this one was my
favorite one of all of them I
surprisingly feel that way to really
which one was yours
cuz you just watched all of them self
yeah well I think the most shocking one
was which one was the most violent one
thing is this I second one yeah the
second one was kind of shot and you're
like what is easier to understand the
interpretation was definitely easier to
grasp on this one Allah you tube videos
will go shockingly violent to make you
go uh and then we remember that you
share with all your friends this one
wasn't about like let's not go for the
typical YouTube route of just throwing
and random violence let's go crazy in a
different kind of scary spooky way with
the digital you know what I like in this
video too was like the little dialogue
band uh banter they don't really have
that in the otherwise you don't anyway
guys thanks for telling us that was out
if you knew the channel you can
subscribe to the real reject OHS and you
could subscribe to Veronica Sixto
chêneau does music and blogs okay and
Brandi does independent movie robos she
is like Rando a Prai so the best and you
can follow us on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram oh alright and we're gonna do
a shout out out oh oh oh hey hey hey Oh
Jason are a can hey how did you get to
be so awesome give me a shout-out next
day well I'll tell you I was raised by
very muscular men they grew up in the
woods became naturally buff through the
yard worked in the wood lumber drip
lumber work lumber raised by Lumberjacks
I was raised by lab urge acts you were a
lot of plaid yeah are there any females
missing
no I didn't see my first female till I
was 18 no wrong that's the typical
American age I was an adult at 15 then I
saw my first woman she was my first wife
she's dead now not because of me but cuz
I'm ever on I left my wife for Veronica
and now my wife is dead because not
because of him she took too many you
don't don't do it occasionally that's
how he became so awesome oh yeah you
know you'd never make anyone off of my
face you grow up by lumbermen and then
you get a hot ass girl that's true
awesome not everything is awesome that
everything in my life is awesome
especially baby that's right smile for
the camera come up come on your little
smile for the camera thanks babe
goodbye Jason